[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and my
god take a look at that future this is
the brand new xiaomi me mix the new
world's most interesting phone in my
opinion so you remember the sharp aquas
crystal from a couple years ago that
bezel-less phone that i've showed before
but with the chin that kind of made it
look like an old zoon hd
this me mix is a 2016 reincarnation of
that concept and it's beautiful i love
seeing companies go all in on like crazy
unique gambles like this people like to
keep saying smartphones are boring well
sure we've technically seen this before
but this phone takes it to the next
level i don't care it has a
91.3
screen to body ratio so almost no bezel
on any of the three top sides and a
small chin
the huge display flows right up to the
edges of the phone so it just kind of
looks and feels like you're holding just
the display in your hands it looks like
the future and this time it's a 6.4 inch
display so you're fitting an absolutely
huge screen into the footprint uh just a
little bit larger than some phones today
that have a 5.5 inch display it's
obviously still going to be a huge phone
for pretty much everyone obviously i
couldn't reach all the edges with one
hand and i usually can with any phone
but of course xiaomi thought of this and
they included in the software a unique
little little feature to bring the
navigation buttons further up reachable
on the display so you can reach them at
any time
fun fact this is also actually a 17x9
display which is why videos don't
completely fill it like they did with
the crystal but pretty much everything
else does especially if you capture your
own media and the corners are curved i
don't know how much resolution from the
official number you're going to be
losing from this but that curve that is
pretty all four corners of the display
are curved and like i said the chin
isn't even that big this time this feels
much more 2016 you still have all your
display drivers and your hardware and
the front facing camera and everything
down there but it's now all in a chin
that's still smaller than the one in the
pixel which isn't even bezel-less
obviously it really makes other phones
bezels and edges look big so the
advantage again to having this display
go right up to the edges one the camera
the viewfinder looks amazing it kind of
looks fake at first actually but yeah
taking photos and videos with this
camera is sick really immersive
watching videos is also dope when it's a
native video since it's a 17x9 display
you also leave the nav buttons up and
don't lose any screen but if it's
youtube or something some third party
app it hides the nav buttons and then
you get these little black bars still
looks pretty great though and yeah just
generally everything involving content
you're going to have this much more
immersive experience the display looks
great you got to get like a sick
high-res wallpaper obviously get all
your apps and games they're going to
look great going all the way to the edge
now the disadvantage number one would be
because it's so close to the edge
accidental touches but the edge
rejection and the software already seems
pretty good so that's a good sign so the
biggest con now is probably durability
because you know obviously if you drop
this thing without a case it doesn't
stand a chance with almost no protection
and this polished ceramic body is about
the slipperiest phone of all time
seriously and as far as i know there's
only one case for it the one that comes
in the box and no skins for it so really
really it's incredibly slick if you
don't like the included case you're out
of luck but i guess at least the one
that it comes with is actually pretty
nice at keeping the modern look and a
pretty frameless image
now this is already miles past the sharp
aquos crystal as far as usability you
can see it's running android with myui
on top of it we already saw the
usability feature for having the big
screen and that's because this phone is
actually going to be sold it has a price
roughly 500 bucks and a date that it's
going to go on sale november 4th so this
thing is real uh the phone you're
looking at the one i'm holding right now
has a snapdragon 821 chip
six gigabytes of ram
256 gigs of storage a 24 bit high
quality dac
dual sim card trays a 4
400 milliamp hour battery and a 16
megapixel camera it's ready to hit the
streets i mean these are top-notch specs
so the proximity sensor that's usually
in the top of the phone has been
replaced by an ultrasound sensor for the
same purpose and the earpiece for
hearing your phone calls that's also
usually at the top is now a
piezoelectric speaker that vibrates the
metal frame of the phone to generate
sound this is a smartphone concept dream
come to life and i'm more than happy to
share this kind of stuff with the world
again an easy route for a company you've
never heard of is to just build
something that's really close to what's
already familiar with people that's a
big reason why you'll see so many iphone
clones but this crazy gamble of a phone
that they actually made that's actually
meant to be sold i love it i love it
it's like if you said smartphone design
was getting boring this one's for you
welcome to 2016. it's not even available
in the u.s right off the bat but i hope
it does well enough over in china that
they do bring it over here i'm glad it
exists what do you think would you rock
this just throw a pixel launcher on and
call it a daily driver let me know feel
free to sound off in the comment section
below that's been it thank you for
watching and i'll talk to you guys the
next one
peace
[Music]